to meet his mind people and to people  now thinking that it's what the world  thinks social media has mined people  into thinking that the comments below of  posts are what the world must be feeling  and thinking about you  the insecurity levels have raised to an  all-time high because my belief is now I  posted something people are saying these  things underneath I don't want to go  outside because this is how they feel um  so I've now put this [ __ ] in my head  that as soon as I walk outside if you  look at me you talking about my post  ain't you huh what post  you saw my post didn't you and that's  why you looking at me like that I don't  what do you what we now think that this  is the way of the world right and we're  so engulfed into it that the negative is  so loud that you don't even see the  positive